[Música]
bom temos a maior ou uma das maiores
biodiversidades do planeta
isso mesmo na escola isso sabemos isso
vemos na internet e nos jornais
tudo bem mas e daí que ele está fazendo
com essa biodiversidade mineração
aproveitar as riquezas do subsolo
hidrelétricas que inundam essa
biodiversidade
ok temos que explorar essas riquezas mas
as riquezas que estão na biodiversidade
afinal de contas temos riquezas e
mensuráveis na nossa biodiversidade
temos vários biomas que compõem o nosso
país de dimensões continentais floresta
amazônica cerrado caatinga pampa
mas entre elas a que possui a maior
biodiversidade da mata atlântica que
normalmente quando a gente pensa em
floresta vamos salvar as florestas já
vêm à nossa mente floresta amazônica no
nosso quintal a gente tem a mata
atlântica está e egito que faz com essa
mata atlântica tem vai para o litoral o
processo da mantiqueira o mesmo aqui em
piracicaba no interior de são paulo e
santa catarina conhece um pouco da mata
atlântica é aqui uma floresta densa
fechada muito parecida com a mata
atlântica ea floresta de bornéu que há
controvérsias entre o qual tem a maior
biodiversidade da mata atlântica oferece
bornéu
e olha só a mata atlântica restam apenas
oito por cento na sua cobertura original
nestes oito por cento sistemas a maior
biodiversidade do planeta
essa riqueza que a gente tem distribuído
em todo o nosso litoral ou perto da
costa a sua o seu maior mas isso é no
vale do ribeira
isso quer dizer que a maior porção de
floresta contínua da mata atlântica que
a gente tem no vale do ribeira que a
região mais pobre do estado de são paulo
o que riqueza é essa que não reflete uma
riqueza econômica que não reflete numa
riqueza social
tudo bem para os botânicos agrônomos
biólogos ecólogos né
temos uma riqueza de espécies entre anna
k de arce anonáceas rosáceas um mundo de
metástases pra mim tem eu porque esses
nomes pra mim se traduzem nessas frutas
nesses alimentos em taió bomba em
araruta jabuticaba goiaba e isso me faz
eu tenho uma cicatriz na perna num tom
kelley uma goiabeira na casa da avó
quando era pequeno
comendo goiaba e aí você pensa nessa
variedade de espécies
você vem você pensa nessa variedade de
matérias primas e como nós somos seres
culturais
cada um desses produtos pode dar
centenas de alerta nessas matérias
primas podem dar centenas de produtos o
que vocês estão vendo aqui é ver o peso
só farinha de mandioca no pará porque o
pessoal da bahia como farinha da bahia
que é diferente da saída dessas farinhas
do pará
bom a exemplificá um pouco essa
diversidade e por que que eu me enquadro
nisso e como vocês se enquadram isso tem
um exercício que sempre faz quando vou
falar de alimentos que gostaria de fazer
com vocês agora
eu quero que todo mundo pense no prato
na fruta no doce que mais gosta
normalmente quando faço exercício dois
fenômenos acontecem
primeiro um sorriso isso reconforta o
outro aqui quando eu pergunto esses
pratos têm nome e sobrenome a a canja da
tcheca lucie ou é o pimentão recheado da
minha mãe pra mim é o doce de abóbora da
minha avó que tem abóbora aquela pescoço
da cahb açúcar e canela muito açúcar mas
mais que isso tem a vó porque na verdade
esses gostos e gosto é relativo porque
cada um tem seu gosto e educado o gosto
se aprende
o gosto é manipulado a nossa memória
afetiva mais que sabores crocância aos
sons que esse elemento equipamento emite
tem a nossa memória afetiva tem a nossa
identidade
tá eu tenho certeza que aqui se não
tiver nenhum francês e europeu na
platéia
ninguém pensou em um creme burnley ou
para ele jogar arroz feijão bife e
batata frita tenho certeza que vários
porque isso porque isso tá na nossa
memória afetiva isso nos faz ser quem
somos
a gente não estava muito valor assim não
deixou de prestar tanta atenção mas a
nossa memória olfativa e gustativa ela é
muito mais significante do que a nossa
memória visual e auditiva tenho certeza
que a grande maioria que se lembra do
cheiro da casa da avó
o cheiro
pra nós enquanto indivíduos enquanto
seres humanos
isso nos dá identidade e por isso a
nossa alimentação está muito ligada à
nossa identidade
um trabalho que eu fiz com os caiçaras
no litoral norte de são paulo em um
lugar onde era isolado único acesso era
barco na década de 70
rasgou cerri o santos no meio da mata
atlântica na década de 70 toda a
população do vale do paraíba em cidade
de são paulo caíram 1 pro litoral a
levando a modernidade para esses
caiçaras numa das falas um caiçara que
viveu essa época ele me falou lembrou
é na escola a gente é comido peixe e
quando perguntava pra gente a gente fala
joão como bife mas tinha comido peixe
tá isso é um exemplo da desqualificação
ou da indy floria inferiorização da
cultura que o alimento faz parte que o
indivíduo faz parte
normalmente quando isso acontece vem em
seguida uma exploração altamente
predatório que foi isso que aconteceu
já a nossa cultura caiçara tá morrendo
teve uma vez que fui para são sebastião
aqui no metrô paulista fechar e pega o
peixe e eu vi caixas e caixas de uma
empresa aqui em piracicaba
tá
e isso acontece porque não tem peixe não
tem peixe mas todo mundo quer coletar
linha vai procurar o que é começar um
bom né e temos peixes maravilhosos
diversos que não têm valor econômico
começa a cultura se dá através de nossas
memórias da nossa memória olfativa é
muito forte né a gente tá um problema
muito sério que a padronização do sabor
temos espécies agrícolas diariamente
entram no mundo uma padronização de
sabor e assim uma padronização de
identidade uma crise de identidade uma
crise social e econômica
nunca nos preocupamos tanto com alimento
e nunca comemos tão mal
nunca fomos tantos habitantes do planeta
e nunca nos sentimos tão sozinhos nunca
a depressão se propagou tanto o alimento
o alimentar é um ato social humano
perdemos isso hoje porções são
individuais
você não compartilho aqui no kit da vida
atua fonte da vida e isso é primordial
para o ser humano
queria falar um pouquinho também quanto
à biodiversidade 11 no meu trabalho com
o palmeira juçara que segundo gonçalves
dias que minha terra tem palmeiras onde
canta o sabiá
as aves que aqui gorjeiam não gorjeiam
como lá eu estava exilado ele estava no
litoral de são paulo
jussara alimentos abia provavelmente
estava falando jussara que o que a gente
tinha na mata atlântica antes disso aqui
vocês focar um pouco mais vai ver que a
sua primeira
hoje essa palmeira tem extinção tá
a gente fez um cálculo em 2009 75 por
cento do palmito juçara que estava no
mercado era clandestino 75 por cento
indo para restaurantes pizzarias tá
levando à extinção essa espécie que
demorou 12 anos para crescer
olhamos para o fruto que é um primo do
açaí e tiramos a polpa deste fruto do
açaí tem uma ideia um produto nacional a
fota sendo chamada de super fruta
jussara a polpa de juçara tem
às vezes mais antioxidantes do que o
açaí o açaí foi considerado pela fruta
por causa do antioxidante alguém que já
tem uma polpa alguém conhece porque isso
não foi explorado ainda tá porque temos
a uma desvalorização de nós mesmos da
nossa cultura da nossa raiz a polpa de
juçara quando você tira ela do fruto
sobre essas sementes da uma alta a
viabilidade em um ano uma empresa que
prestou consultoria
produzimos 17 toneladas de sementes está
na produção de sete toneladas de polpa
por que ir lá fora o mesmo aqui dentro a
gente tem um produto nacional a sair
2 a castanha do pará que se tornou
castanha do brasil porque lá fora já era
falado de castanha-do-brasil e os
parentes ficaram muito bravo com isso né
que perderam até castanha do pará
enfim a eu tenho certeza que se tivermos
tortas alimentos ovaia de cambucá dp que
prova da nossa riqueza gente
o cara vai querer comer a pessoa vai
querer ter aquela sensação de ratatui
para que você morre você toma você se
remete a você a tua memória afetiva
afinal de contas temos uma riqueza
imensurável na mata atlântica
vamos melhorar isso vamos utilizar vamos
empreender as nossas riquezas
o que a gente faz hoje tira essa mata
atlântica planta cana planta a soja para
evitar ser maçante seja ou frutas
exóticas
essas dessas frutas esses alimentos têm
um potencial econômico afirma pra vocês
são verdadeiras bombas de vitaminas e
antioxidantes que nós temos a nossa mata
são verdadeiras
a soberania seus fornecedores para a
gastronomia sabores gostos texturas são
procurados hoje em dia o que a gente
está fazendo com essa diversidade
tá temos que empreender temos que dar
valor a nós mesmos e assim dar valor aos
nossos produtos
assim a gente começa a falar de
preservação tá só para a gente ter uma
idéia a história do palmito clandestino
os palmiteiros que cortam palmito no
mato altamente carentes
eles cortam furtam e por palmeira como é
uma cadeia clandestina em 2009 chegou no
valor de r$3 por palmeira morta
uma obra que demora 12 anos para crescer
por trabalhando com o fruto
chegamos um cálculo de 20 reais por ano
por palmeira e aí a gente começa a
apresentação dando valor para a floresta
em pé então e daí vamos agregar valor
vamos utilizar o que é nosso para nós a
força da nossa identidade
obrigada
[Aplausos]